there's kikuchi for the season 21 start
seven and six is three seven three era
struggle coming out of the all-star
break but his pitch well in his last two
outings
did he go he wins is tony rendazo
strikeout of marcus simeon so two outs
sixteen innings that game he threw back
in august 18 of 19. man that was a
wonderful performance
self-defense he knocks it down dug out
by france what a play
both ends you say get gucci to dig it
first by time france that'll do it for
the
toronto blue jays in a first inning wow
23rd start of the season his 13th start
on the road in his first ever here at
t-mobile park here is ty france he is
swinging it four-game hit streak how
about these numbers eight for 16.
center field straight away and deep
springer give and grab goodbye
two-run homer and just like that it's
two-nothing mariners here in the first
inning
ty france with home run number 12
50 and 51.
and scott service was talking about it
today he says ty france does not get
enough credit for his field
and hitting so one down and here's tay
oscar hernandez t oscar d.h tonight
oscar lifts a flyable to right center
field this one's got some carry to it
and it's going to go
opposite field home run to oscar
hernandez number 19 on the season and
the blue jays are on the board well what
a start to the second half he has had
that will give him 31 rbi since the
all-star break only joey vado in
cincinnati has more runs in the major
leagues more runs driven in with 35 and
te oscar stays on this pitch this is a
beautiful swing now the bases are loaded
after an e5 and two walks
needed that strike three call his best
fastball at 95 miles an hour
kakuchi trying to get out of some
serious
second inning trouble one two to
springer
got him looking wow
a great escape in the second inning to
keep the mariners in front two to one
because of the last inning the error in
the two walks this pitch count has
jumped up on him
slow roller kakuchi
he's vying for a gold glove tonight you
say kikuchi with two outstanding
defensive plays and ty france with
another pick i think we know about it
good athlete gets off the mound no
problem there spans
the short hop over to ty france the
delivery super moses spins
it was a pretty good fastball a tie a
couple of men on with one down top three
blue jays down a run grounded up the
middle for a base hit
guerrero around third in to score beshet
stops at second an rbi single for
hernandez and the blue jays have tied it
swaying that's a big strikeout
for a city guy like me who knew it would
be so cool to walk through a field of
corn
stalks
foreign 64 runners go both of them
thrown out for the secondary run yeah
he's up the bag that's a break that is a
big break
score
is tied at 2-2
2-2 pitch with two out two on
struck him out wow another
huge escape by kikuchi who has stranded
six the last three innings
it sounds like he can come back
relatively soon as you mentioned
possibly on tuesday
what a pitch there by ryu right on the
inside corner for out number one five of
the six pitchers that pitched as
starters in the buffalo series are
pitching again in this series
and it's another base hit for vladimir
guerrero jr he is two for three now on
the night
two and one infield looking for a double
play
instead of high fly ball deep right
center field similar spot as before
ball gets away after the collision
vishet getting the stop sign he'll stop
at third
catchable ball
fernandez thought he had it
they both go up to get it yeah
catchable couple men aboard with all
this action it's still a 2-2 ball game
hopefully it'll stay this way for a
while lourdes has reached on an air and
struck out field is back for the
mariners as guriel hits a slow chopper
to third this will get a run home
the shed into score give goriel the rbi
tay oscar to third and the blue jays
lead three to two
his
arm side command has really been zeroed
in here
after the first inning
and he gets some swinging at the curve
ball and hyunjin ryu is in a groove he
has retired
14 in a row
[Applause]
ground ball to short to second one on to
first for two
buchet gives marcus a good feed samia's
got a strong arm and they're able to
double up the crawford so that erases
the impact of that lead off single young
ryu back out there bottom seven
drives the ball to center field
and it's off the wall
springer is down
france is on his way to third
and will be in there and
the concern will be with george springer
now he got to the wall he knew he was
going to have to jump and then he was in
a very vulnerable position looks like
it's his leg what an effort by springer
and then you could see him grabbing his
ankle immediately when he came to the
ground that's not good news at all
here's a 3-1 to terrence
high drive left field that's plenty good
is it going to stay in the yard and gets
out of here
that is a clutch three-run
jack kelly goes the other way
gideon baby
[Applause]
jk with a home run
and it's 6-3
murders
one-two pitch
going to get it done
here comes hanniger everybody up 90 feet
7-3 mariners here in the eighth abraham
toro got just enough to pick up an rbi
his eighth as a mariner 28th on the
season faces juice nobody out 7-3
mariners
luis
high drive
left
off
field
fence scoring his friends singer on the
hustle he scores
two more all aboard and the mariners
blowing it out here in the eighth
luis terrence back to back
late appearances driving in five runs
sadler middleton swanson now miss cevich
here's the 3-2 pitch
to beshet
and
this will put an end to it right here
mitch haniger settles under it
and this about as satisfying a win as
you want to see here a 9-3 victory over
a good toronto ball club